[music playing]
NARRATOR: Osaka, Japan.
In the middle of this modern
metropolis like the Daisen,
Kofun, a tomb for one of Japan's
long line of divine emperors.
Covering over 400,000 square
meters, the Daisen Kofun
is considered the largest
tomb by area in the world.
There are more
than 160,000 kofun
dotting the Japanese
archipelago, all of which
contain the remains of emperors
or their royal families.
DOMINIC STEAVU (VOICEOVER):
There are burial
mounds throughout the world.
However, there is
one specific shape
that exists only in Japan.
And this is the keyhole kofun.
Most of these can only
be seen from the sky.
This raises the question as to
why emperors would be buried
in such a way that they're
actually being memorialized
and being seen from the sky.
MALE SPEAKER
(VOICEOVER): The Japanese
believe that the royal family
was descended from gods
that came from the sky.
So we have to wonder, is this
a way for the extraterrestrials
to identify the tombs
of their ancestors?
NARRATOR: Could the
thousands of Kofun dotting
the Japanese islands
contain the bodies
of extraterrestrial beings?
Curiously, in 2016 researchers
studying high resolution photos
of the surface of
Mars spotted an eerily
similar keyhole shaped mound.
MALE SPEAKER (VOICEOVER):
Is this possibly a
Kofun found on Mars bearing
some last extraterrestrial god?
If so, we can see that
there's definitely
a connection between what we're
seeing on Mars as some type
of Kofun burial site
and over 160,000
of these found all over Japan.